hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in articulating
for us his theory of moral development
Lawrence Kohlberg sets out a number of
distinct stages of moral development and
he also tells us that he's more
interested in form rather than content
when it comes to moral reasoning now a
lot of the early work that he did was
with school children but he also worked
with in prisons and he would carry out
these experiments where he would set up
a dilemma and I'll tell you about the
dilemma in a moment and then he would
ask people to say what is the right
answer here and then to give some sort
of justification for their answer to
explain a little bit further and the
situation has to do with this guy Hans
and you could do with other situations
as well other moral dilemmas as a
particularly good case Hans has a wife
who's sick and the pharmacist will not
allow her to have the very expensive
medicine because Hans does not have the
money to pay for it the question is
should Hans then break into the pharmacy
and
take the medicine which will allow his
wife to continue her life or should he
not do that which is the right thing to
do but more importantly why and this
goes directly to this issue of form and
and content for when content not just in
terms of our thoughts or our verbal
expressions but also in terms of our
actions and this is what makes
Kohlberg's theory so interesting for
Ethics besides the classification of the
six stages he's very interested in what
we would call practical reasoning that
is the the way of using our Faculty of
Reason along with our other faculties to
arrive at decisions and judgments about
what is good and what ought to be done
or conversely what is bad and what ought
to be avoided now if we think about this
in terms of form and content content he
tells us in moral development a review
of the theory really encompasses two
main things the first is what people
think is right or wrong and he's not
quite so interested in that on its own
for its own thing again form and content
content matters because there's a form
that gives that content its its location
its context what people think is right
or wrong by itself is not that important
or interesting
what's important is what they do with
that and how they arrive at that
likewise she says they're behavioral
responses by themselves you know which
would include actions but could also
include say attitudes maybe even we
could talk about you know the the
decisions that are made are kind of a
behavioral response as well or somewhere
in between behavioral and cognitive
those two are just content so what is
the form
and he takes us actually from from John
Dewey who he brings up along with Piaget
he says like Piaget Dewey's idea of
development does not reflect an increase
in the content of thinking but instead
of qualitative transformation in the
form of the child's thought or action he
says what we examine in our work has to
do with form rather than content right
we are not thinking or describing what
people think is right or wrong whether
draft evading exiles should be given
amnesty or you know thrown into jail
when they return to this country or even
what what changes in what individuals
think as they grow older and here he's
referring to another one of his his own
articles he says that what we're looking
at here is cognitive structures
cognitive structures underlying what
people think is right and wrong
cognitive structures underlying
behavioral responses the thing that
actually connects all of these together
and what we can observe when we ask
people why do you think that's right or
wrong why do you feel the way that you
do and they explained it to us so he
goes on and he says for example this
this structure refers to the general
characteristics of shaped pattern or
organization of response rather than the
rate of intensity of response or its
pairing with particular system stimuli
it refers to rules for processing
information or for connecting experience
of events now how do we translate all
that jargon into you know moral theory
really what we're talking about here is
how a person carries out his or her
moral reasoning and decision making
whether it's their own whether it's a
proxy for somebody else whether it's
about some hypothetical case that is put
in front of them this is the form the
thought process that they go go through
and then set down in words so that we
can
see it it also includes what they are
referencing in explaining or justifying
their views how they're taking the
things that they value how they're
taking the things that they think matter
or right and wrong how they're taking
those into the situation and connecting
them up with the ultimate need to say
yes or no right or wrong do this don't
do that now at different levels like for
example at level one you can ask a
person why did you do that or why didn't
you do that action or why should a
person not do that action or in the case
of Hans why should Hans either steal or
not steal the medicine and at a level
one they might say well you know Hans
shouldn't steal the medicine because
he'll be punished the the police will
come and beat him up and throw him in
jail and it won't do his wife any good
but it's really bad for Hans to go in
jail cuz he'll they'll hurt him there
well that's a level one that's a an
explanation of why he shouldn't do that
that thing you know at level four there
might be another thing well listen the
rules are the rules it's unfortunate
that Hans doesn't have any money but we
can't have people going around breaking
into everybody's pharmacies when they
need you know some sort of thing that
they can't pay for society can't take
that we have to protect society that's a
level four justification and that is a
different form for a similar content the
similar content being Hans keep your
hands off different explanation for why
that's the case similarly if we take a
level three response and then maybe a
level six response hans loves his wife
so much that he will break in and that's
the right thing for him to do because he
doesn't really care that much about the
shopkeeper that's his neighbor but he
really loves his wife and he
wants his wife to stay alive and for
them to be happy together that's all
level three response right Hans is a
nice guy he was a good guy and he has a
nice girl that's a level three
orientation what about if we put it up
to level five or level six maybe at a
level six you could say well Hans
recognizes that he cannot sacrifice the
humanity within his wife merely to
uphold you know values important to
society like not breaking people's
windows and taking their stuff human
life has a priority over mere material
right we invoke something like a conch
in distinction between what has genuine
value and what only has the value that
we call trade or use value right some
things have cost other things in dignity
that is a level six form response but
both the level three and the level six
response saying Hans Brandt get in there
take the medicine give it to your wife
both of them are working with the exact
same content so we can have the same
content and in a different form and the
form is what determines whether a person
is in fact at one stage of moral
development or at another so that is
what Kohlberg thinks we need to focus
upon
you